you can argue if you would like that
there was a legal predicate to start the
investigation it doesn't really matter
to me what I'm here to tell you and the
American people if it started legitimate
it became criminal pretty quick here's
what I'm going to say to Horowitz do you
agree with me that in January 2017 after
the sub source told the FBI and the
Department of Justice everything in the
dossier is a bunch of BS that's when it
became a criminal conspiracy to defraud
the FISA Court instead of telling the
court that the primary sub source
disavows the dossier they told the court
they were truthful and credible at that
point in time people at the Department
of Justice and the FBI defrauded the
FISA Court trampled on the
constitutional rights of Carter page and
continued a surveillance of a duly
elected president unlawfully if it
became as if J Edgar Hoover came from
the grave and took over the
investigation in January 2017 it became
a criminal conspiracy I want to know did
did call me no did McCabe know what did
they know and when did they know it and
I want to know did the Muller team know
about this